- [Mark] Okay, Alicia.
- Hello.
- [Mark] Where are you from originally?
- [Alicia] I'm originally
from Alma, Michigan.
- [Mark] Alma, Michigan? Where's that?
- [Alicia] Yeah,
it's like right in the center
of the state of Michigan.
- [Mark] Oh okay, I'm from Detroit.
- [Alicia] Oh okay, I'm
from like Central Michigan?
Yeah so, that's where I'm from.
- [Mark] Welcome to LA.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] How long you been here?
- I've been here this time nine months.
- [Mark] Oh, you're new.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What got you out here?
- I left my husband of 18 years,
and we lived out here before,
so it felt like the city
was just calling me,
you know to come back.
- [Mark] Why is that?
- I love this city, I love this city.
I don't know why, but I do.
- [Mark] You're in the, as they say,
the asshole of the city
right now. (laughs)
- Yeah, the bottom of the bottom (laughs)
- [Mark] This is the garbage can.
- Yep.
- [Mark] So, let's start
with your childhood.
Tell me how you grew up.
What parents were like-
- Yep, I had both parents
up until I was 11,
and then my dad did some
stuff and he went to prison,
then my mom became a single mom,
and then life got a little hard, so.
- [Mark] Why did your dad go to prison?
- For molesting two of my friends.
- [Mark] Oof.
- Yeah, when I was 11 he made me watch,
and there's just crazy
stuff that, you know...
- [Mark] But you weren't molested?
- No.
Nope, he didn't touch me or my sisters,
I have two older sisters.
- [Mark] But you had
to watch your friends-
- I mean he might as well of-
- [Mark] That's almost worse, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
So, and that was in South Carolina,
and then we moved back to Michigan.
- [Mark] That's hard.
- Yeah, yeah it was a little rough,
especially comin' back when,
you know kids are mean,
so when I came back they
already knew what was,
small town talk you know, everybody,
my dad was well-known in the town so,
it made my life,
I had to start fighting at that age
to keep my head above water,
so my life flipped around
from being innocent
to havin' to basically
grow up real quick at 11.
- [Mark] And then
where'd it go from there?
- I got in a lot of trouble,
became a delinquent basically,
I'm the black sheep of
the family as it is,
so like it just came
to be where, you know,
me and my sisters,
my oldest sister had her own
place because she had kids,
I became an aunt at 10 years old,
so she had her own place,
my other sister lived with me,
and she became kinda like my mom,
because my mom was workin' two jobs,
she was hardly ever home,
just to keep food and
house over our heads.
I just went the other way,
you know fightin' and gettin' in trouble,
doing drugs, and that's
where I felt comfortable
after all this that happened,
so I don't regret anything that's happened
because it's made me who I am today,
but you know I wish I
could take some back but...
- [Mark] Do you have kids of your own?
- Yeah, I have five.
- [Mark] Five?
And what ages?
- I have an 18, a 17, a 14, a 13, and 10.
- [Mark] And where are they now?
- My oldest three live with my mom,
and my youngest two live with their dad,
my husband that I just left.
- [Mark] So you're out
here living on the street,
or are you...
- I'm in a tent, yeah.
Somebody stole all of my identification
when I first got here,
so and I'm from out of state,
so it's really hard to get
my identification back.
- [Mark] That's terrible.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] People get
stuff stolen every day.
- Yeah, I don't know,
I think I've been through like 30 tents
since I've been here,
replaced clothing numerous times,
it's just, it's crazy out here.
They'll take anything they think is value.
- [Mark] And so what's your drug?
- I dib and dabble with
cocaine, crack cocaine.
- [Mark] Just crack?
- Yeah.
And weed, I smoke weed.
- [Mark] How long you been doin' crack?
- On and off for about 18 years almost.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So while you were
having kids and everything?
- Yeah, I stopped when I was having kids,
and then you know...
- [Mark] Got back on.
- Things just...
Just didn't go as planned.
- [Mark] So you've been clean for a time?
- Oh yeah, I've been clean
for a length of time,
you know 10 months
here, nine months there,
couple years here, you know,
other than that I've
always went back to it.
Even though I can maintain a life,
it's not that I can't maintain my life,
it's just, you know I'm
a functioning addict,
that's what they'd call it.
I know I have a problem,
I know I do.
It's just,
right now, I don't care to deal with it,
to be quite honest.
I was, I mean I was with
my husband from 18 to 36,
my birthday's in a couple weeks too,
I didn't really have my
life, you know what I mean?
It was like I was a mom and
a wife from the age of 18,
I didn't get to have this,
so I'm like taking me now,
you know for a minute,
so that's what I'm trying to do
is just do me and find out who I am.
- [Mark] So are you still
in contact with your kids?
- [Alicia] I haven't talked
to them in a couple months,
but you know me and my husband
are still good friends,
we're not on bad terms at all.
- [Mark] Are your parents around?
- [Alicia] I haven't spoken
to my parents in 10 years,
since my youngest was born.
We had a lot of fall outs,
my mom and dad didn't like my husband,
they feel like because
he was older than me
that he, you know, took me away from them,
and influenced me into getting into drugs.
Nobody influenced me,
I mean yeah, granted he did it,
but I chose to do it you know what I mean,
I don't blame him for that.
But the drugs caused me to
sign rights over to my
oldest three to my mom,
because of the things we were
going through at the time.
But my husband is the
father of all my kids.
- [Mark] And what do you
do for money out here?
- Uh I do...
- What a lot of the girls do?
Yeah.
It's taken care of me for nine months,
I haven't had to rely on,
and you know I never had a pimp,
I always tell 'em I'm my own pimp,
I take care of myself,
I say what I want to do
when I want to do it,
not nobody tellin' me what to do,
and thank God,
by the grace of God,
nobody's tried to force me to do,
no pimp or anything like that around here,
you know they've all, they
respect me for what I do.
I don't think what I do defines me though,
because if I had my ID,
I'd have a job.
I'd rather work than do this,
but it's quick money right now.
Unfortunately.
- [Mark] What do you have
planned for the next five years?
- I'm hoping to have a
place with my kids out here,
that's my goal.
And to have a nice job.
- [Mark] And to get clean.
- And get clean, for sure,
that'd be the first, you know.
If I wasn't down here, I
probably wouldn't be doin' it,
because there's so much
other things here to do,
than our small towns that we've lived in.
I've lived all across this country though,
me and my husband,
before we came out here in 2016,
we traveled the country with our kids,
my 13 and my 10 year old,
so we've been up and down
the coasts, both coasts,
across, like I said, east
to west and south to north.
We've been everywhere,
it's been an adventure.
- [Mark] Good luck from here.
- [Alicia] Yeah, God's got me,
I know He does.
He's got a better life for me,
He had me come out here for a reason,
and I've always wanted to be,
not so much a drug counselor,
but to help people that
are on the streets,
and, you know, because I've
been in their predicament,
so I know what it takes to get out of it,
if that makes sense.
And hopefully my story can touch somebody.
Because I've been through a lot,
I don't look like it, I
carry myself very well,
but whew, it's been a life.
- [Mark] Thank you for sharing your story.
- No problem, thank you.